- (laughter) What are you doing?
- So tonight I'm hosting a
slumber party for a few guys
around the office because
they've never had a slumber party
before and they seem pretty clueless.
- Pillow fights. That's a thing, right?
- Pillow fights, for sure.
- Yeah, no, pillow fights are not a thing.
I've come up for a few
activities for them,
so I hope they're excited.
- Yeah, very excited.
- I am so down.
- So, I'm sitting here and
it's been legit almost an hour,
I have no clue what they could be doing.
- Any whipped cream on that?
- Oh yeah, for sure.
- Jasmine, what are we gonna be doing?
- First, you guys are going
to be applying face masks
to each other.
- That feels great.
- That is like a legit mask. (laughs)
- Don't shake my head too
much, just lost a cucumber.
- You kind of look...
- Terrifying?
- Oh god.
- Look, you're supposed to try and relax.
- There you go, now just relax, buddy.
- More with your fingers.
- I'm going to, I'm just
squeezing it all out first.
Uh oh, I got some on your
onesie too, by the way.
- Let me take off my face.
- Whoa, dude.
- It's like peeling the
plastic off of a new iPhone.
- You're the new iPhone.
- I'm the new iPhone.
- So I'm deciding on having
them do a two minute manicure
because it is the hardest
thing to do and I also think
it's ever harder painting
someone else's fingernails.
- I look really good in green,
but I also like the color purple.
- Do you wanna do both?
- Let's do both.
- Gustav, how's your family?
- My family is great, can't
wait for them to see this video.
- Kenny, you're gonna look fabulous.
- Thank you.
- (laughs) Shit.
- Believe in me, okay?
- I believe in you.
- This ring finger looks like
it's doing a walk of shame.
- I did a pretty good
job with you. Am I wrong?
- No, absolutely not, it was horrible.
I had the worst set of
nails at the entire party.
- The third activity will be pillow talk.
I'm having them do pillow
talk because I feel like it's
a good activity for everyone
to open up with each other.
We've only seen each
other around the office
and a little downtime afterwards,
so this will be really
good to dig in there.
So where do you guys see
yourself in like five years?
- I don't like thinking about that.
I don't even know where
I'm gonna be next year.
- I would like to think
that I would be working at
least someplace where I'm telling stories.
I mean, that's why I moved out here, so.
My endgame really is to
just make enough money
to support myself and my
family, doing what I love to do.
- Are you planning on being
married in five years?
- I don't know if I'll be
married in five years but--
- When do you think you wanna get married?
- Really late twenties to early thirties.
- I don't know, I see myself later.
Like mid to late thirties.
- I feel like I would be
okay with getting married
like late twenties but
then waiting to have kids
so that I could travel.
- There's a lot of things
that we unfortunately have
to let go as we get older,
so as an adult, to be
able to just pick a night
of the week and just put on a onesie,
as silly as that all sounds,
it's incredibly gratifying.
- Should we do this again?
- I'd be down for that. Also
if it's a larger slumber party,
maybe like seven to ten people.
- That many people could
build a dope ass fort.
- Oh man, we should've built a fort.